it is making policing in America more
dangerous by the rhetoric that they're
spilling which which is false do you
think it's possible that we're gonna
also and maybe were there already are
gonna have a crisis in policing we're
good people
yeah forget their skin color yeah which
I would prefer to do all the time but
good people who are policemen won't want
to work in black communities because
they know will ultimately be an
unwinnable situation you'll either have
them turning on the black officer like
you and you're the sellout and all that
and the white ones will just be like
we'll forget this there's no win in this
I could be a great officer for 30 years
right but one weird thing happens that
gets twisted one way or another or
edited or whatever and my career is over
so then you're gonna get a I don't even
know how you call it like a lower class
of qualified people that are gonna work
in the communities that need it the most
right and then people are not gonna
they're not gonna be proactive in
policing we've already seen it happen I
mean if people are now thinking that
we're going to get to that point you're
so hot we were there we were there from
Ferguson people don't realize it the
crime rate and these errors are
skyrocketing officers proactive policing
is going down the wait listen
police are responsive right they respond
to crimes right if I mean you got into
an altercation I pulled a gun I shot you
they're not there before I shoot you
they come after the fact but the
greatness of policing if it's done
properly is proactive policing therefore
they've already had contact with me
understood that I'm a danger I probably
gotten arrested for crimes I've done
before before I'll shoot you that is the
way you police but the reason I mean the
what they're doing today is they're
killing the spirit of officers being
proactive because you go you see a guy
doing a hand the hand people without
come without the experience in law
enforcement say I was just a hand a hand
know that hand to hand has killed so
many people in the community with drugs
and crime and all this other stuff we
see that we arrest the man hand the hand
we get into a scuffle with them now in
police brutality we get fired officer
sees hand hand and say I'm not gonna
care more than the community does
because it takes a lot man it took for
you to risk life life and death everyday
and put your family through that and you
want it at the end of the day you want
to get your pension and you lose your
pension over something you did correctly
over something that you were justified
in doing but because the community
became outraged you lose at all we saw
it in Baltimore all you got to do is
look at the stats Baltimore huge
reduction huge reduction in applicants
California whose reduction in applicants
and we've seen this on the Tucson Police
Department and they won't tell the
public because the chief is a piece of
crap but we have to dumb down the scores
because we didn't have enough qualified
people to join the police department
when I was there you had to make a 75 or
above and this is a test that you can't
study for you got to become out the gate
having a basic understanding now they I
think they put it down to like 40%
offices on an apartment or like and I'm
gonna tell you this any department you
can look at the stats Tucson is a big
example when they did this a while ago
you see officers getting fired out of
time I'm just doing bad stuff they're
skipping over backgrounds it is making
policing in America more dangerous by
the rhetoric that they're spilling which
which is false yeah these are lives that
they're telling you Michael Brown
this still is talking about hands up
don't shoot LA Eric garner I will fight
to the death
about the justification of use of force
against Eric garner Tamir rice all of
these shootings and all these things if
you're police officers you understand
that these are just the five uses of
force people conflate the to justify
killings is what they call it or killing
somebody versus the justification of use
of force there's a big difference they
weren't trying to kill Eric garner the
dude was fat overweight heart condition
you use any force against him he's gonna
go into cardiac arrest
he's like a time a ticking time bomb
they weren't trying to commit a kill
Tamir rice the young kid did he had to
pulled a gun on him he got put in a bad
position he used force against him
unfortunately that one shot caused his
death so people begin to conflate the
two we can never address the real issue
because we're not talking about real
problems right and the interesting thing
is of course you're not defending the
incidences where they're Jenny when
they're genuinely are bad guys but what
people always forget about is that that
that constant threat that you guys are
under you just don't know what's gonna
happen on a knife's edge whether that
guy has
nor the other thing so sometimes you
have to be what what would I guess
appear to be visually more careful than
maybe the average person would want you
to be what is what I teach you in
Academy and I know this is not popular
people probably be mad at me for saying
this we get taught an Academy and I when
I first said this to me I thought was
the most extreme thing in the world on
my are they going too far what they
teach you the Academy is that you and
not everywhere where I went in my
Academy yeah you have to be prepared to
kill every single person you interact
with you have to be prepared emotionally
to kill every person that you interact
with because if you're not you're gonna
die you're gonna get killed and you're
gonna get all your other buddies killed
so you have to be able to have the
mindset that at any moment this person
can turn on me whether or not they're a
kid whether or not they're elderly woman
because we've seen a spectrum of
officers getting killed by all kinds of
people you have to be prepared for that
and people don't understand our
perspective this is not a video game you
don't get to hit the reset button when
you die you die for real and you're gone
forever and unique part of what we see
is that we see people die every day we
see the last breath we see a person
pleading for their life and in the
officers mind it's like I don't want to
look like that when I die I don't want
my family to see me like this guy I
don't want to be it my last breath not
being able to talk to my son on the
phone you need to do the right thing
I'm gonna miss meeting you I'm gonna win
people pose threats all the time right
you just think about how many I pulled
my gun when I was officer four or five
times a week people have guns yeah I
didn't escape death I don't know how
many times people don't see that side
every officer has their own perspective
about life all right we may go to the
same car you may have been shot before
I've never been shot so I'm green behind
you I'm driving in there no caution yeah
the other officer may have a reflection
in the mind of me and last time I got
shot cuz I did this next time I got shot
I seen a guy pulled it from here but I
didn't react fast enough they get to the
car here you go
fully named shot you get what I'm saying
so the more the more of the story is
that we do go through a lot and if
people understood they will be able to
see these shootings in a month
clear light all right so let's shift
this a little bit to politics which will
get us to blegh sit so most of the
cities in you you mentioned Ferguson you
mentioned Baltimore the cities where
there are the most shootings Chicago we
can go through the list of these cities
people don't seem to want to accept this
or at least mainstream media doesn't
want to accept this that these are
Democrat ruined cities right but I
thought Democrats like black people more
than you mean Republicans yeah well
what's calm here something's not adding
up because it's not true I can't be say
it's like if if the the standard is two
plus two is four and you see an equation
I said two plus two is three is
something wrong there people or not it's
politically expedient for them to evade
the issue and you say well the virtue of
having a D behind your name is cop no
it's not it's the policies think about
this who's anti police Democrats and
what are they doing there cause the
police not to act there cause a police
to be the enemy of the people
people aren't snitching they're not
cooperating with police now crimes
aren't being solved but those things
have have issues they want you to be on
full staff they don't want you to be
independent they don't want you to go
out and get it on your own
they don't want jobs to come to your
community they don't want that they need
you to meet them so they can win votes
when you say they are you talking about
like you're talking about the political
class because I believe even for I mean
you know enough about my political
evolution for as frustrated as I am with
the lefties these days most of them I
think are just misguided I don't think
they're bad people I don't think they're
really trying to screw over black people
or something like that the elite do it
and they're easy bumper-sticker answers
give more money to this community for
this sounds good get the police out
there police are killer like it all
sounds kind of right but I don't think
the average person actually believes
that no but it's breaking through that
right layer of it's not the people right
you can even look at this in a spiritual
sense of a pastor right the people the
lay members are receiving information
from the pastor in in hopes that he's
acting in good faith to project the
gospel right he said he got a degree you
believe him
you're learning from him people in a
Democratic Party the people the lay
members they are listening to these
politicians hoping that they're telling
you the truth about immigrations he said
Republicans are always
so you're hoping that they're telling
you the truth but they're lying to you
and it's the people at the top but most
of these Democratic people that are
running for Congress I'm not even every
Democratic person in the house there are
some people that are like uh never know
more reasonable but the party line idea
the party line politics is what's
destroying people and it's almost like
this look I think I look at I equate
slavery and then the freedom of slaves
to the Democratic Party today and this
is how compared to to when slaves were
on a plantation they knew what's wrong
whatever the case may be the slaves
didn't want to be there but when they
got free wouldn't the slave master tell
them oh wait how are you gonna survive I
got there on y'all who's gonna take care
of you you're gonna have food we can
feed you we'll take care of you make
sure you're safe stay here in slavery in
a lot of slaves did they felt
comfortable they didn't want to go out
on their own in which the big bad world
become entrepreneurs be free the
Democratic Party is almost the same
similar concept because black folks need
to be free we need to understand that we
can be entrepreneurs we can be flight
attendant we can do it all they don't
want you to go into this big bad world
and fail failure is only a pathway to
success if you never fail you will never
be successful they don't want you to get
off the plantation they want you to stay
so they can coddle you and then what our
communities become desolate if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell